hey guys Ryan Wright and Jerry there you
go buddy
way to instill some confidence here
we're gonna be doing an honest trailer
or a Thawne we're doing the rest of
phase 1 we posted our reviews for Iron
Man and The Incredible Hulk yeah and
then we'll do phase 2 for another video
so after we watch the video we'll do a
little mini review based off what we
heard in the video whether or not we
agree or disagree oh it's gonna go it's
time to challenge screen junkies to
their opinions well you know I mean
these are always a little nitpicky
so I read you boys
from the poor man's jaw swing comes the
forgettable follow-up to Iron Man that's
essentially just killing time until the
Avengers Iron Man 2 the completely
disappointing sequel you fooled yourself
and lucky simply because it had Iron Man
in it suit up
we're ready to reiterate of the Nick
Fury bonus II from the end of the first
Iron Man which will still be unresolved
by the end of this movie
Tommy Stark not not recommended we
witness
Tony's do our battle global terrorism
and his inner demons now prepare to see
him take on his biggest challenges yet
tedious government commitees can you
please read page 57 paragraph 4
requesting that I read specific
selections from unimportant yes sir
corporate maneuvering it was an illegal
seizure of trademark problems low
batteries I'm not a coal has been
depleted alcoholism and some guy with a
bird I bought it by the book this is a
bird back in Russia a sequel so inferior
it will replace an awesome origin story
with countless subplots you won't
remember as soon as you walk out of the
theater a story that ditches technology
grounded in reality for laughably
unrealistic magic Holograms which - a
tree parking lots exits Patience's
and substitutes Jeff Bridges with Garry
Shandling do you or do you not possess a
specialized weapon witness a superhero
movie with just enough Ironman action to
fill a three-minute trailer but not a
feature-length film trust us we counted
instead sit back and prepare to watch
Ironman attend corporate events eat
donuts deejay birthday parties and pee
his pants experience the epic face-off
between Ironman and one of Marvel's
least known villains whiplash whose
harnessed the most dangerous modern
technology ever only to waste it on a
whip puffle with no known superpowers
who somehow survives being crushed by a
car not once not twice but four times to
defeat this madman Iron Man's bringing
in backup and they are all just as
boring as the rest of the movie however
pods an inconsistent nag who's totally
cool with her boyfriend being Iron Man
but freaks out what he drives a car this
cannot happen Black Widow a sexy spy she
warned into the movie just to establish
her boobs for The Avengers and
Lieutenant Colonel James Rhodes nope no
no not that one
yeah that's the one who has the skill is
too perfectly fitted and pilot an Iron
Man suit this experience way didn't Tony
need like half a movie to figure out how
to work that thing a new chapter so thin
the key to the entire plot is resolved
by a 40-year old Easter Egg from Tony's
dad Tony have built this for you whoa
and Daniel feels
who dead got earlier so his/her own son
would keep his old diorama put it in an
impossible to predict holographic
computer display that can magnify
impossible amounts of detail and reveal
the chemical makeup of an impossible to
create element unfortunately it is
impossible to synthesize which Toni
immediately synthesizes in order to
replicate you have created um you uh
someone got paid to write this story
Robb Stark missus Coldplay better
Terrence Howard some guy in a Mickey
Rourke mask oh that guy from um you had
one movie a guy on the Garry Shandling
mask Vince Vaughn's BFF Don Draper Sam
Elliott no man it's bugging me and
Hawkeye with pubes Iron Man to Sam Robb
well it's Sam Rockwell that's the guy
I'd love to man Galaxy Quest thanks for
watching be sure to subscribe okay I
still like ya I like I'll admit the we
saw Iron Man 2 I did not like it when we
first watched it but I've been watching
all the movies and released they order
again seeing it after watching The
Avengers it's actually better because
you doesn't feel as much of a vendor
shoehorn cuz the world makes more sense
now ok so it doesn't feel like you
already feel a part of this role you
already feel like Scarlett Johansson's a
part of this world and Nick Fury is
coming so it doesn't feel like oh
they're just trying to promote the
Avengers yeah I mean a lot of this is
just nitpicky stuff like yeah Don
Cheadle wouldn't have been able to
figure out the suit that fast but but do
we really need another 40 minutes of
suit figuring out you know like it's
that stuff I don't mind losing really
I'm still not appreciative of how sci-fi
technologically like jams just yeah like
beyond all the crazy like it's it's a
little too insane like I have a good
point about like Tony's dad cream this
little Easter Egg and then Tony just
goes like [ __ ] insane with it and is
able to conjure up an element like it is
like a little bit ridiculous to me yeah
I mean I know I don't mind the Holograms
really
like you know from the beginning it's
all been about like hey this dude can
basically make any technology that's
crazier than any other technology and
we're so used all these Holograms I
don't mind it as an aesthetic choice
like of course it's unrealistic all the
stark technology is so like that doesn't
really bug me it's a little convenient
that it's on this diorama but that's a
different plot point in it as far as
like the overall picture though I don't
agree that it's a boring film like no I
think - I personally like the film a lot
more now that I've seen it again we got
enough ass-kicking in the first one like
yeah let's let's see the aftermath of
all this let's see what happens he's
getting like he's got to go to court you
know he's got to go these places yeah I
like seeing alcoholism
I like seeing those internal struggles
that he goes through with this like you
know and it makes the action more of a
treat that one yeah
like the actions cook the action isn't
maybe not like necessarily cooler in
this and this one by the Iron Man movies
have always been about Tony Stark at the
end of the day if you think about the
first Iron Man there's okay let's count
the action sequences when he breaks out
of the cave he goes to was at
Afghanistan or Iraq when he saves the
day I forgot airplane sequence
Tony versus a fight Obadiah that's four
scenes out of I don't count this if you
don't know this be more kind of school
if I'm missing one I'm sorry but there's
there's probably only like 20 to 30
minutes of actual Ironman action in that
one the rest is Tony Stark
so Tony Stark is Iron Man like that's
who we come to see and I think that's
what makes them really interesting to
watch I like Sam Rockwell a lot in the
movie I like make you work a lot yeah I
like the supporting yes yeah I thought
they were great so I don't really have a
lot of problems like all these problems
are what I had when I first saw it but I
actually understand them more so they
don't bother me as much yeah it's like I
like the side characters and all that
stuff you know in this franchise
especially it's easy to get away with
not having lots of action because people
just like watching Robert Downey jr. be
Robert Downey jr. yeah and I don't mind
the stuff where he's falling apart like
I like that so that makes it more
interesting to me I mean like I made
more sense to me first off of the
nitpicky stuff about him getting in a
race car that is more dangerous cuz the
Iron Man suit [ __ ] protection
yeah the race car so he could fly out of
it and just break his neck and [ __ ] and
whiplash you know putting the power and
the whips he says in the movie that he
just wanted to make God bleed so he
didn't intend to kill him he just wanted
to I mean he could have accidentally
killed of all [ __ ] his vendetta is what
Iron Man himself it's not like
necessarily about world domination the
whole point was for him to show that
Ironman is not God not by killing him
but he's like you know if you make go
bleed
I could kill him I mean I think it's
just because they've got that whole
vendetta back from way back when you
know and I like the birds is very
personal I do too
bird stuff was funny it's fun you know
I'm moving on a Thor let's do this boy
howdy another yeah
prepared for a film that only exists
sewn on nerds will recognize the blond
guy
the Avengers 4 you've seen great
superhero films you've seen terrible
superhero films now prepare for a
superhero film that's just kind of yeah
I mean I guess they did the best they
could adapting a comic book about a
bratty space god you are no fool journey
to Asgard the land of fighting myth
where everyone gives a pointy hat the
gods live inside the CGI pipe organ and
the own body it around this is a rainbow
movement from Mario Kart I know I didn't
get an auditable marble heroes since
Doctor Strange he's an idiot demigod
prince with a magical hammer that really
needs to buy about the only near you
yeah what's me ah yeah those are the
only gotta tell me Loki Thor's evil
stepbrother who will stop at nothing to
betray his adopted father with the help
of his real father
I will conceal you and you can slay him
way lies in order to betray his real
father dad came with his son to impress
his adopted father I could have got a
father for you
that makes even less sense that is
playing from the Avengers not repine me
Odin Thor and Loki 'he's dad who pretty
much guarantees that one of his kids
will grow up to resent the other only
one of you can ascend to the throne both
of you were born to be kings
Oh and all these rejects for more than
regime of Thrones and single warrior
princess sin reject struggle with the
former god of thunder as he stripped of
his powers and baggage to these two
square blocks in the New Mexico desert
there he'll acclimate to our strange
Earth customs like ordering in
restaurants no he'll care you're not
much for the party traffic safety and
horse purchasing anymore little purses
just dogs and give me one of those large
not too rough watches Thor turns to Jane
Foster for help
a brilliant astrophysicist with
supermodel good looks that just happens
to be single and who immediately falls
in love with or for no good reason
Vanessa's reasons as so right long ago
as he loses then regains his magic
powers hooks up with Jane saves two
different realms from destruction and
learns the
juice of patience and humility all over
the course of a long weekend seriously
this whole movie takes place over two
and a half days
starring Thunder from Down Under Pokemon
took Godfather Idris elbow Lord said
from powering news and Portlandia doors
obligatory movie so low-key dies at the
end it comes back to life by the end of
the credits that's gotta be some kind of
record hey screen junkies um okay okay
now okay I know honest trailers they're
supposed to make fun of the movie
they're supposed to sort of bad on it
but you know when they're like kind of
being real about it and you know when
they're just making fun I don't think
they necessarily put the movie down that
much actually it made fun of it but Thor
is not a boring movie at all it's funny
- well Thor's a lot of things like you
know part of it is this kind of fantasy
movie and then part of it is this
fish-out-of-water story and I enjoyed
both of those you know and I I'm glad
this is part of what I like about Marvel
is that it's not just a superhero movie
it's also a fantasy movie cuz they said
like Oh Thor's just okay but Thor is one
of the ones that actually impressed me
the most because a harder one to sell
people on because it's you know it's not
of this world you know it's Early's not
entirely of this world they had to
translate Asgard to screen which is hard
to try to translate Asgard to screen and
then have it cut to a story on earth
where it's a fish out of water tale
we've seen movies before we're like a
knight is transported to the pressing
turn people yeah people do stories like
that and or like someone's time-traveled
into the past and another stuck there
when you hear like a scar that earth and
to not make that a goofy comedy yeah
it's kind of hard
they made both worlds work well yeah
they had enough comedy and enough action
I liked all those choices you're having
Thor be the god of thunder but then he
gets to earth and he has to like learn
how to actually be worthy you know I was
like yeah like all this stuff like make
him work for it before we get the end
together you know I've seen uh Thor at
least four times now every single time
I'm like why in the world does Natalie
Orman like Thor so much makes more sense
- but why is Thor in love with her like
it every time I watch I'm like there's
no content in here that makes me go
these guys really love each other you
know yeah I mean I'm not in love with
that character in any way I mean I'll
sucks because it's not only Portman yeah
and I mean I like Natalie Portman I
could take her or leave her sort of in
Thor like I really liked her in like
Black Swan Oh like in this movie I'm not
really huge on she's nine she's not bad
she's just not one of the more
interesting characters yeah it's like I
mean I'm gonna take a lot of flack for
this but I I'm much more enjoyed an
exempt Natalie Portman in this movie
because at least she's you know humorous
and colorful true
you know the Portman has some good
comedic lines in the movie yeah she does
but she sort of has to play she has to
wear all these hats of like super-smart
exposition mover beautiful love interest
you know reason for a Thor to change you
know she doesn't feel as much like a
character as much as she does a device
device to move the plot you know we saw
the Iron Man 2 1 which was making fun of
how they shoehorn stuff into the movie
of the Avengers but I love what they did
with shield in Thor like it felt
authentic a part of the world it didn't
feel like god more Avengers promotion
well this was also when I was getting
more rapid - because the Orang Captain
America were pretty close and in this
movie it's not as in-your-face as an
Iron Man - because in Iron Man - it's
like you're a whole scenes dedicated to
like kickin it with Nick Fury and like
Natasha Romanoff as a character and then
in this like you have a couple moments
with Hawkeye don't you but like yeah
like a moment and when they implemented
shield they kind of viewed them at
versus possible enemy yeah what is this
outside yeah then you've been a Lincoln
yeah it was good I think it's really
good so yeah two more to go Captain
America the First Avenger oh and then
the Avengers yeah nothing - it's all
good my brother let's do this
America time imagine all honest trailer
fans from from the studio dumb enough to
sell their Marvel franchise rights to
Disney comes in a nom it only exists to
set up the Avengers Captain America the
First Avenger stand tall for a superhero
movie with an important message it's
what's on the inside that set for when
it comes to fighting or being respected
look at breaking the crime or getting
laid
women aren't exactly lining up to dance
with the guy they might step on meat
Johnny Storm the Human Torch wait no
that's wrong Willy meet Steve Rogers a
grown man's head CGI'd onto a little
boy's body he's a skinny kid from
Brooklyn who dresses like it's the 1940s
so basically a modern-day kid for
Brooklyn
watch as he becomes a superhero hunting
in the most American way possible
steroids
he'll juice up to become Captain America
a soldier with the powers of being a
little bit stronger than a regular
strong guy Ultimate Frisbee and super
sobriety I can't get drunk
Tony Stark's ridiculous 3d holograms and
return to an analogue world full of
lever bullying
actually like all that stuff I knew to
practice which clothing
when Prezi I mean of course
as mikail intervene
and people calling up percentages with
absolutely no context per se shevardino
said 50% percent that's forty sixty
right along with captain america as he
faces off against the evil Red Skull who
long everyone else inside by and fantasy
is played by Hugo as the captain defeats
his legendary arch-nemesis in a brisk
two-minute montage all to leave more
time for foreshadowing the Avengers
introducing the plot device from the
Avengers unnecessarily freezing himself
so he can be in the Avengers and an app
you credit scene that is literally a
trailer for The Avengers starring the 90
year old virgin Tommy Lee groans one
face to face red face view face German
Capote not dr. Strangelove the winter
spoiler agent love interest and robert
dan senior Captain America the First
Avenger traitor
Raiders of the Lost Ark is better just
saying hey screen junkies
okay okay um I know this movie is where
we like disagree oh yeah I personally am
NOT the biggest fan of this film I like
this one a lot I always go back and
forth um like what my favorite of the
phase 1 movies are but I really like
this one a lot it might be it's more on
top of it yeah it's definitely not for
me what I admire about it I really
admire about it the production value I
think is really yeah I mean I love that
they put this movie most Ian I like this
sci-fi in the 40s I thought that was
pretty cool with its like technology
that's not updated yet as far as really
defining Captain America and who he is
it really isn't that definitive other
than like he's a good guy would like
super strength and a cool shield I think
it does you know sort of establish who
he is at heart who he's like the spirit
of who this guy is and what he
represents you know it does but my
biggest issue with the film is honestly
I felt like it could he used another
half hour to an hour and I'm really okay
without what I actually liked it up
until
they started montage in Captain America
kickin ass because I felt that all would
have been interesting to see how they
play out because they're like hey it's
cap the Captain America's finally got
respect okay he assembles a team it's
like with interesting characters so you
got Bucky and then Bucky dies but I
don't really care cuz we didn't really
get to know Bucky that well there's
other teammates who were gonna forget
about because cap got frozen and now
they're like whoa we're just gonna
forget about those guys and I feel like
I still cool in that movie I feel like
it could have been like an interesting
like mission tale of those guys as well
like a half hour of that would have been
cool at least scene 1 full mission play
out I think they do a fine job cuz they
have to establish him as a regular
soldier first and then have him take on
the super villain you know because it's
a war movie but with super hero
trappings so it's like I don't think we
can spend all that time watching him
defeat just regular soldiers no I'm
talking about when they're working as a
team they montage the whole team stuff
and I felt like there could have been
some great like intense moments and some
cool teamwork to also establish the
other characters a little bit more like
as they set it up as alright we got
these cool new personalities but you
don't really get to see what their
special traits are or you don't walk
away remembering what they are and I
thought we did but really what do they
do what are the other teammates do no
teammates do I don't know they they all
work together what it would are all
regular guy is it like maybe I felt like
they'd started rushing at that point and
it sort of losing my interest and I
don't like the villain stuff that much I
think that's all I like the bonus of
what yeah I get bordel you'll probably
remember a lot more of the fine details
cuz you watched it like just yesterday I
liked all the stuff with the Reds Cohen
and Toby Jones and all that like hey I
was gonna get really bored whenever I
see that is it that was the third time
I've seen it and it's a war movie to me
like I like that stuff I think a lot of
it's technically there but I feel like a
lot of it was also kind of rushed and I
do feel that it was a little bit like we
got to make sure he's in the adventures
maybe the end but whatever whatever I
want you to change your opinions not at
all I just I just like Steve Rogers in
this I like this sort of 1940s aesthetic
I like watching him go through
camp and all the stuff with Tommy Lee
Jones and Stanley Tucci ya know that
those love interest makes more sense you
know and no that stuff's all great all
the war stuff and all the strategy stuff
all the you know different things and
then all the villains stuff with you
know the Red Skull and Toby Jones like I
like pretty much everything they put
into this I like the first hour a lot
more than I do the last all right guys
the Avengers you can't really make fun
of this movie too much let's face it
everyone knows it's practically perfect
there's probably only gonna be like
nitpicky stuff in here I never know
from joss whedon god of the Nerds comes
the rule blockbuster that finally unites
the world's four greatest superheroes
that Marvel still has the rights to the
Avengers the ultimate to our geek
fantasy that lines all nerds from
admitting any legitimate criticism and
put all of DC Comics on suicide watch a
villain who inexplicably returns from
the dead will vow vengeance on the plan
where his demigod brother sort of
girlfriend lives forcing this bluetooth
obsessed government agency to assemble
the heroes from Marvel's greatest
franchises except spider-man Fantastic
Four and x-men suit up with Iron Man
everyone's favorite secondary Marvel
character who must redeem himself from
the god-awful Iron Man 2 Thor who sort
of fooled off his own movie but whose
appearance here completely negates its
ending Captain America no one's favorite
character who just kinda has to be there
and The Incredible Hulk who for the sake
of the plot can now suddenly control his
rage among without any explanation which
doesn't matter because that shot was
awesome what is being excitement
I need you to get to the edge of the
trophy a fireman repairing a spaceship
for 20 minutes the thrill of generic
aliens on fly jet skis the confusing
energy source of the tesseract the
tether I can fight you can protecting us
and it's completely unjustified
fail-safe the explosion that instantly
kills every alien convenient retiring of
all loose ends the romance and a
director in the middle of the credits
whoever nerd in the audience pretended
to know a movie so fulfilling you won't
remember that the first 25 minutes are
actually kind of boring Naz I trained
you feeling so determined you know the
cube to bring me out
you'll wonder why you should nighty the
only people who can stop it in hopes of
getting them to dislike each other not
every plan battles so action-packed
avail you won't even ask yourself how
are they even all talking to each other
without earpieces do it no wait stop
these things are still coming pinkeye i
man poopy not Edward Norton the Human
Torch leather bruise makes me do and
Gabe a Marvel's The Avengers if this was
a major areas of squiggle delight you're
likely dead inside or a girl if you like
honest trailers and please check out our
brand new weekly series my favorite no
it's definitely not because you really
can't find much wrong with the Avengers
and there's not much to make fun of
because it's [ __ ] awesome yeah I'd
really really pulled things together
despite huge pressure and expectation
the only thing I sort of like walked
away from that with like you know what I
that is a question that I had I feel
like I found the answer through thinking
about it was how was banner able to
suddenly control the Hulk but I remember
in the Incredible Hulk
that if something triggered his anger
prior to him not trying to channel it
intentionally he couldn't control the
Hulk but like at the end of the
Incredible Hulk he's able to channel it
and then be able to control a hole
because he's like I don't know preparing
the mentality or some [ __ ] of the
monster in him and then same thing with
the Avengers like he gets triggered and
then it's like he's trying to fight
against it but when he embraces it is
when he can actually control it it's
like one angers and controlled any
channels but there's another form of
anger that causes him to be out of
control it seems like a least worthy
explanation or one worth discussing
you've obviously thought about a lot
more than I have it worked for me in the
movie partly because it's like when we
meet him it's established that he spent
so much time away you can tell like it's
probably got a lot to do with him
working on that yeah you know and so
yeah cuz at the end of the Incredible
Hulk
it ends with Edward Norton like he's on
a run and then he goes into his little
cabin and then you see him meditating
and channeling the Hulk
like he's intentionally trying to get
there through meditation he does work on
being able to control it yep movies
perfect can't really say anything anyway
guys thanks for tuning in for phase one
of honest trailers
you can catch our Iron Man movie spoiler
talk and The Incredible Hulk spoiler
talk on this channel as well if you're
new to the channel you you you and you
can subscribe to the real rejects and
you can check out Jerry's playlist
reasons to Jerry where he does movie
reviews and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
trying to get product placement from
Disney I would really like product
placement a lot is cool
I want toys mainly is what I want if I
could just get a lot of toys I'm talking
Star Wars Marvel make some Black Widow
total no no no Kenneth Carrasco Wow
hey Ryan I love your videos and I'm
inspired me to soon start a reaction
channel myself what is up with all these
people starting reaction channels firing
like I know I'm too inspiring
you guys are awesome whoever is your
guest is awesome cool and beautiful all
the girls in the channel are incredibly
beautiful can I get a super badass shout
out um yeah I could do that for you
bus to be Kenneth
Carrasco for you alga homo I want to go
on your dick and blow blow my
girlfriend's in the other room right now
she wants to get out of the room right
now then filming for two hours looking
at honest trailers I'm going in here
looking at Ken's where did our masks
were tasked with this task want to do
this stuff gotta go by fast and it won't
last what Kenneth is here he has no fear
yeah go around here and I still make
jokes that make me sound like a queer
but is that an offensive what I just
said well man I'm saying I want to give
Ken that's a good head but he might be a
little kid so if you are kenneth then i
didn't mean any of this I'm gonna go
take a piss yeah we should review their
profiles before we rap about them in
sexual matters